mind your decisions I'm presh tell
Walker find the coefficient of x to the
power of nine in the expansion of the
following binomial product the first
term is 1 plus X multiplied by 1 plus x
squared multiplied by 1 plus X cubed all
the way until the last term of 1 plus X
to the power of 100 this was asked on
the jé advanced exam which is a test
used for admission into India's
prestigious IIT colleges pause the video
if you'd like to give it a try and when
you're ready keep watching to learn how
to solve this problem
[Music]
let's analyze this binomial product
consider the term 1 plus X to the power
of 10 what happens if we multiply X to
the power of 10 by ones in all of the
other binomial terms we'll end up with X
to the power of 10 notice the exponent
is larger than X to the power of 9 so
this will not contribute to the
coefficient of x to the power of 9
similarly if we have 1 plus X to the
power of K where K is greater than 9 if
we multiply this by all of the one terms
in all of the other binomials we'll end
up with a term that is an exponent
that's larger than X to the power of 9
so we don't need to focus on any of
these terms to get the coefficient of x
to the power of 9 we'll only go up to 1
plus X to the power of 9 and then we'll
distribute this term with all the other
ones in all of the other binomials so
let's analyze this binomial product will
recall an exponent rule X to the power
of a multiplied by X to the power B is
equal to X to the power of a plus B
where therefore going to count the ways
that the exponents sum to 9 and the
exponents are the numbers from 1 to 9
will then multiply the result by ones
from all of the other binomials in the
product now here's a simple observation
one plus two plus three plus four is
equal to 10 and that's greater than 9 so
we can only have three two or one terms
in the product if we have four terms
we're gonna get to an exponent that's
larger than nine so let's enumerate the
ways if we have one term we just have X
to the power of 9 for two terms we can
have 8 plus 1 we get F 7 plus 2 we could
have 6 plus 3 or we get F 5 plus 4
what about three terms one way is 6 plus
2 plus one another way is 5 plus 3 plus
one and a final way is 4 plus 3 plus 2
there's no other way to get to a power
of 9 interestingly the problem relates
to number theory because these are the
part
of the number nine from the set one
through nine we count these and there
are a total of eight ways and that's the
answer just for fun we can input this
into Wolfram Alpha and it will verify
that the answer is eight incredible
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on YouTube as
always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]